Ok three things. Universities big cultural reasons. Sure. Fifty seven.
And i work at the university of sydney
and i've been here for about fifteen years still doing a lot of the things that i did when the.
Prodigy queries festival. I was tutoring here and a university of new south wiles.
And was more involvement with students who were also interested in the audiology is that in the protest
and the radical movements of that time. And who desperately wanted to be involved in exploring some of those paths.
And it was through that.
University commitment and the fact that the aquarius festival was destroyed and you know students.
Event that we could quite legitimately get involved in i was capable because i worked also at new south wilds of
involving the students architecture students at both universities. And i was very keen. I didn't have to do too much.
And there was a solid group of students from yourself wiles' and from sydney who got involved in the planning.
And in the construction of. Some of the facilities. For the festival. But prior to that i can recall.
Very early in the post might be a year or two year and a half perhaps before the festival started being approached boy.
Johnny alan johnston.
And i can recall my first meeting with him on you john any wife from the yellow house at king's cross.
But we had a meeting at my office at the time which was in the by create. Paddington and.
We were talking about the festival and.
How it might be set up and where it will be set up and about some of the ideas that much more.
Be brought to bear on it. And i remember at that stage.
I think it was graham dunstan was saying that by them were attracted to the area around mullumbimby
but for various reasons. It might not mine or the coup there. But that general region which.
I forget who coined the word ride by region but. It was that region that we were talking about. And i can remember.
Advancing. The idea.
Since all working to try and have a larger agenda for the festival to help with the day centralization movement.
Because i had just done a job for the department as centralized.
Through the university of new england called my client where i'd had a lot of contact with local towns playbill
and also in the district. And i was very sad about the fact that they kids were leaving and going to the city and.
Not continuing the role tradition. And the townspeople also very kind to attract. Development.
Looking at their town declining and the population declining and very worried about about the future and.
What i was there for was to help sort of plan a strategy for the future of this. I was very conscious of that.
And i remember realizing this to. Johnny and sighing that. There was this problem of a.
Of a concentration of population. Moving to the big cities. And the rural areas.
Hadn't been able to attract new settlements or. Business like new rule developments.
And it was a non-factor that the north coast in particular the dairy industry was declining and.
No matter how much funding. The department of decentralization injected into it didn't say interest that decline.
So we were trying to look at a bigger picture. As well as. Being a festival and enjoying the fruits of that.
And it was all sides. From our point of view. University.
Involvement was a grant to try some experiments and to say what would work. Well.
I can remember being in name but being in. I think we all we met up at least.
And i think it was tom zubrycki had a cat. And there were four of us. There including tom and joy and myself.
And with author.
We were cruising the area looking for inspiration and sots
and i think brian in particular was very keen finding something like a wilderness area like a wonderful place to be.
And to have a festival and in a fairly unfitted why try out a lot of new systems.
And so i suppose we were looking for a special saw it.
And we none of us would talk seriously about recycling in a town at that age.
And or remember when we first saw it in the name of rocks. It was such a powerful impact. That everybody just said.
You know. Wow. This has to be.
The saw it somewhere around here
and i think the first instinct was to say let's have a festival at the foothills of the rocks.
Not knowing of its aboriginal significance or anything else other than the fact that was just a very powerful place.
But we continued on and to explore around and around the place and. Then we found.
The way when we came into the town and it was village it was. It was a client in a sense in that.
It was almost a mean conditioned. Village with. There's only one shop.
A lot of very little action in the story and anyone around. And i can recall then sighing. This is the place.
And i said. What was the connection between this. Almost a film set. Village.
And the name but it rocks that created that sort of.
Then i should let you know we found the place and now we should sort of concentrate on what to do with it.
I think what the sequence of events after that was that by simply that. One of the things that.
Having just done the out town axis i was very conscious of. Participating with like a playful and.
I did suggest that before we did. Too much else we should have a meeting with the town.
And set up a meeting and start to negotiate with or in fact the town player wanted just here.
But i feel sure i would because of that background of.
Involving and wanting to involve young people in rural values and.
The opportunity to start new laws and i think that the townspeople
and the organizers of the conference had had a lot of common ground. And i actually wasn't there when that.
When those meetings occurred. I had. I went off to china for educational visit you know matings before i went.
We did talk about whether it should be a will or sought. Or whether it should be. What i was.
Opting for which was a degree i did saw it. Like a place where the impact of having. X. Thousand.
Number of people for a couple of weeks. Wouldn't wouldn't destroy the saw.
And i was very conscious of the fact that the impact of having been to other events. Like that and.
What i do remember and several others i was. Way that. You know there was a. There was a terrific.
Potential impact of so many people and. The idea of finding sots close to the town to sort of.
Close to the village to breathe life into the plies
and the fact that there was already a transport connection the lismore there was already some.
Lots of viking shops and one shop. But there were facilities there that could very good eye. The idea of a festival.
And without having to put all the expensive infrastructure because there was a budget repub many why about bringing in
water and handling transport and also controlling it i mean there's a play station if they felt that that was a fact
but there's a hospital. And things like that which in the event. You know useful things to have around.
So it more or less settled down that. Now we wouldn't get out of the rocks. Naman rocks.
I don't think that so it was might have been anyway. And i don't know or didn't.
As to whether we could use that sought
but we did talk very seriously with the honors of the saw its closest to the mine straight of name and. One of whom.
Acquiesced to to letting us use the saw and the other one didn't. So most of our planning work.
Was concentrated on the site where the festival actually you could and. The auditor of the street being part of the.
The festival was actually. Indorsed by the. By the local the local people. Sure the general idea of recycling.
Was very strong.
And we would talk about recycling all sorts of things i mean i wanted to actually jump the skylab to a cycling a town
but. It was a natural extension of. Risotto. Weissmann resorting building materials or recycling anything. I mean.
Rather than putting energy into new products. I mean that was very much part of the audiology.
And that found for me but the audio of recycling a town and not building a lot of stuff that was already there.
There was a lot of interesting. Things like solar energy. I mean what.
What in fact is probably now one of the same does of cell he found a splice in him
and there was a lot of the stuff that came out of the whole earth catalog
and the thinking that kind of out of there people were very anxious to explore.
Like building their own structures minimally. And in fact. It was a venue.
Most people who kind the kind with the idea of building. New sorts of structures.
You know also ideas about using weist just as and things like that.
To handle sewage and that sort of once were there was intense interest in vegetarianism and new why's of of cooking.
And also eating different sort of products. Starting.
There was a growing interest in soybeans and many things like that it's cheeses and. And also in fruit. You know.
There was it was no accident people used to cite people would run they would agree and. If i says.
And it's no accident that they write about kefaya they started up a sort of a very old. You know.
A challenging sort of food venue that appealed to a lot of people specially was opposite the hotel i mean there was a
there was a mindstream. Culture going on one saw the straight with. Hamburgers and beer and there was another culture.
Did opposite. Going for soya burgers and. Going to and things like that.
But from our point of view i mean i was a planner and an architect and.
I was very interested in my students and being involved in designing and constructing the facilities.
So we actually part of the idea was to design. And does ignite. The camping areas and the can.
And the facilities areas. The systems. Which would at least mine tie and several thousand people for a couple of.
Couple of weeks. And we did that and especially with the sort of. Was after claude in that for god.
And then he was the one who. By sickly other endorsed the ideas or challenge them and and.
You know we did other things but. We did have a lot of contact our member with the. Strangely helpful.
In how to handle that many people on friday. Sots. And we also had a lot of contact with the.
Start emergency services in. And we had many many but he's with the logical. With the shark council.
Because ultimately i suppose the side of the service
and the i mean if it was necessary lot of gotten involved somewhere along the line.
But as far as the services with them so i had a health priority.
And a responsibility for health and we were conscious of that. So we did opt for. Pit toilets as being the best option.
And we had the electricity authority come in and big the big. I did post halls bicycling. But in the sense that.
Pit toilets actually. Was sort of crude recycling sewage because wherever the pit toilets were we had planned.
An orchard to talk and supplies. What was revolutionary i think was that the pit toilets were. Well communal.
And i was six. They were the one one of memories is a group of people sitting in a circle.
Having a crap and having a good time to go to extraordinary things like privacy and. Modesty just. Blot out the window.
By side when we planned them we did have.
We did have them in circles but we had a bit of previous here in full camping gear is the priority was given to.
Community facilities like there was a health. Like a hospital. Place for emergencies.
You know places where cooking was done and. Where there was access to the creek water.
The sots for the camping the will a wife in the creek were very conscious of the fact that people could.
Pollute the groundwater very easily. So where they where the pitch would not go.
We were careful not to penetrate the border title. That would have contributed and. We used a lot of materials like.
Parachutes and powers and like the toilets themselves were just haitian and posts and.
Pits and pans that came in squatting. Toilets were very fashionable and. We. We did a lot of. We built a lot of.
Footprint talk about squatting toilets. So when you went to the toilet.
You had an option of a squat or a pain in the water system we just by simply. We did collect water off.
Rooms where we could we could do it.
But we relied on town water and also the creek from cooking
and other places was put into selling to people that were dying and. The general to. Planning of the.
Of the festival days ignited. Packing in. Areas and places where people like. Checkpoints.
People when i come into town.
Will come out of the camping sots head entrance and things like that were very interesting. With a lot of people.
Nor was a matter of if it into the. Like was almost like a display village teepees. Lot of bamboo.
Because people found bamboo in the range
and i persuaded some families to let him have a lot of natural materials people did. With brick. Construction.
The five materials with natural materials. Just a side. Or restocking materials.
Like people building things out of all remember one. Geodesic structure was built out of.
I think it's stunning to me a bit of something like that. The northern style throughout all the printing plights.
Someone fat to use well i could actually put it together. I had a. Unusual looking. Structure. But tents of course and.
Caravans wheel structures.
But the most extraordinary ones i think were normal spans done in bamboo using geodesic principles.
One of the things that they helped us with. I set us up with would not have been emergency services.
Set us up with a telephone. Wallace telephone system which.
Some of the students got involved in being more or less like like a foreman is on a billing job and.
There was a couple of really good. Women students that started to do all of that sort of sought work.
And the students were deployed into. You know. Well that i haven't. I do remember now. I think there was a very loud.
Like and a number of supporters. Had moved into me but and were living there.
And no recall that i was good at that very sad because i didn't make anything was going to happen
and i want to log on saw it now and. And then.
We all went up on a on a big boss like the how a lot of us we had a boss.
Where often even in the middle of the not knowing who was in the middle of the know what it was that they did a time.
And we just arrived in the mindset of nimble and grime and.
A few other people who were eating in the diocese kefaya which was the one that was just suddenly this injection of
energy like just the numbers of people who are committed and that sort of thing. Just started to fall off and.
So we moved out of the sots and started work and. That must have been about four weeks before the thing started. But.
I mean it was good. Good for students good for us and. The systems. You know either primitive.
But i worked there when i would hope that prices over there were health problems people didn't get sick.
And there were some problems but i would miss it i mean. Coping with that amount of people.
And the council were basically happy
and then he moved as he started marriages he people didn't get involved the abbey road called in the cup as part of few
visits but generally speaking. The place would accept i mean a lot of people were experimented with.
Knocking down a lot of any bishan is and whilst the townspeople had welcomed. The idea. When the actual thing occurred.
I mean that we're confronted with.
Extraordinary assault on their senses and of their own ideas about modesty and privacy and.
Drugs and all sorts of things so i thought it was just extraordinary the. The battering that. I think.
But like what i wanted by simply. I got thousands of people. I had a credible injection of funds and energy and.
Into the place. And the first it was i was involved in setting up the afternoon but what. Writings because we had been.
We had realized during the course of the festival that.
You know a lot of people are getting very committed to staying there.
And we're quite anxious to try and purchased some properties to to mike sure that we you know.
We were going to get there
and some people didn't know that the tomato sauce spilling was a part of there were some other prop provide i kept
and things like that were a quad and. I think and title for us was a call.
So that's really where terry my kind of prominence. And then he gradually took over those matings and.
The running really was all the people. When waltz. As a planet always interested in the afternoon but what our idea.
And certainly wanted to help facilitate. What i'd go into the thing.
Believing that he was something that they central out was actually decentralized it was happening it was about lost all
it wasn't about industry or anything else it was about people wanting a different life.
But the people who form the core groups of the afternoon that want meetings.
Actually with a core group that then put a purchased title for and and set up for the ride i can't.
Started tomato sauce is a sort of a drop in center. That eventually got involved in schooling.
In the birthing center in the media center. And even what is what it is now. That. Oh yeah.
I mean at the time i was living with a bunch of other people in a castle crag right on the waterfront.
I mean it was it took a half an hour to get there because it was a two hundred foot cliff.
You had to climb up and down. And it was one of those sort of left out of places but no ideally i mean.
I had found nothing that would have compared with the lifestyle. There and we had a wonderful time.
We had a killing and. We had a pool and. We had gardens and as far as i was concerned we were doing it anyway.
But i must say that. When my mother died which is around that time or inherited a little bit of money.
And i went off and. I bought a property on the whole screen river which was my that was my.
Move to decentralize and i guess a lot of people are worried about nuclear war things like that and.
I was certainly very interested in autonomy. And. There's two things i did one was to set a found a derelict owl.
Hass on the hawkesbury which. Got students involved earlier.
We had a commune there and we actually started to fix up the house and. The gardens.
And that moved towards self-sufficiency and. I still enjoyed teaching and.
One of the things we did at the university was build the autonomous house which was built entirely out of recycled
materials. And that had solid water had a cellar a conditioning system. And there may find a jester and.
A society out of gardens and. Several of the students lived there for four years out of the university.
One of those to get rid of it and win it but of of that we get it up in the first place but it's lasted for four years.
Let it ring general ryder's i mean it was extraordinary.
I saw it on a campus that was full of brick and concrete buildings to fall on this.
What the vice chancellor called a federalist house.
Sit in this bit of ground that actually started to turn into those wonderful god. And we had four. Fairs.
Which were free and. People used to come in and display what i really think that was alternatives which was fair guy.
And that's where bill mollison started i mean he came to this one of the first venues that he got involved in there yes.
There are lots of aboriginal groups and put up and normal.
Structure where of course we experimented with recycling systems and solar energy and.
There's a jesus and a lot of god has got involved in the university of new south wales come over
and build a mud brick oven broadwood wood and. I mean it was that it was. Become a focal point for a lot of.
The question had a solid core and that lots of. I mean it became a place where people could. You know.
Share their ideas to other people and before fairs were really very very successful.
When we ran out of gas after four tours there was nothing more we could science was also.
We got a bit worried about the people who are involved in setting up the house that.
Here we were setting up an absolute. Autonomous system.
Within the middle of a huge city that had all these systems in place and we thought it was a bit.
Bit of an anachronism. Actually doing.
And what we kind the conclusion that it wasn't a system is it wasn't that our pricing wasn't guarded naman
or the holy spirit. Or castle crab or anything else.
What was fundamental to what we were on a bat was actually the chinese of attitude.
And the china engine of personal lifestyle. And a commitment to. You know.
Being aware globally and acting like really you know that slogan.
Was around at the time and it didn't matter with me i mean.
We didn't think it was mattered that we weren't living in a minority or else the fact was that we were challenging.
The system and we were being personally responsible for what we did. And we're altering our lifestyle.
Like we're being conscious about not why sting and we're conscious about not trying things out.
And we are committed to working on systems and. Lies of building that you know what you'd now call societal.
Used to get a bit pissed off that the audience was when i had ideas
or what we thought where it is i'd probably that would our ideas but anyway.
We got a bit disturbed by mindstream culture.
Sometimes adapted them in a classic point was we done a lot of work on solid water collectors with a guy called
marketing who had a fascinating idea about parabolic reflector. And we set up a cheap. Recycled version of that.
And then along comes the hot and produce a system which we for thought was really inferior.
I mean it was using materials that were and. That would energy efficient.
Whereas they'd been firms like baisley for example in south astride. I've been doing.
Systems for years and i've been up in the not in thirty's but. You know i had never caught on.
When i had like gangbusters and i produced these heavy systems that set on roofs where the. And i worked and.
The public bought them. And i feel good about them. I mean i don't think i alter their lifestyle one inch.
But they still continue to use more water than i had to do. And i still have no electric backup systems.
So yeah i did feel a bit upset about that. But i don't now.
I just think that idea is of mice the ideas that were being experimented with have been adopted by mindstream culture
and. Now that's good. I mean. But i think last has been altered materially we're still a very consumer society.
But that by china. I mean there were a lot of the grain movements now which probably had their origins then.
And it was almost a religion. Became a religion and values of permeating at every level.
I think the federal government and other people in places like the water board and. Planning authorities and.
In government and. Very conscious of those values now. It was unheard of for example. Ten years ago. To actually have.
Citizens recycling with the products of the products of the law who governed level.
And i remember going around of the city council arguing black and blue that i should start a pipe recycling program
and i just said are you mad you know. Just doesn't work it's not economic it's. But i have a top.
It's become absolutely essential that cancer would dare not race so i can win new zealand has got it long before stride
and. When i had some wonderful recycling programs.
But there were things like that that i'm very pleased that they have become my story.
When i was in some why this rampant sort of consumerism is going to my people are now aware.
Much more liable were about the fought resources of the planet and. Available. More careful about what. What i do.
We still hope done a lot of things like transport systems.
But they are there people like bigger cities program that are conscientiously trying to get people out of their cars
they try to work places places to live in places or to integrate them.
There are people pushing a lot rile their paper pushing. Better water systems. Or recycling water stored border.
Plating that they saw from the housing department. Believe it or not is now putting in.
Twin water systems in their houses on the outer suburbs.
Because that i mean they recycle it got two systems of water in there.
If a conscious that they are polluting the whole experience. So i'm very happy about all that.
Maybe not moving fast enough and maybe not being conclusive enough.
My big disappointment is august last fall but i still think that's. Of come to believe that's the issue.
And i can get right through to people in a very at the household level. Which is one reason why.
For example at the moment all interested in a very sort of sewage system that actually starts. The household.
Starts and finishes the house on. Basically people.
More responsible than bureaucracies
and people of very same to me to be very willing to a lab bureaucracies to do the dirty work.
And then criticize him for it but if it was at a household level. About. That's where it really matters.
Just as just as the community had been capable of handling the recycling. Idea. I think i could take on.
Just take it one step further and now start looking at their water supply their stormwater and their sewage.
There's another thing i want to add. Which i perhaps should have said. Some tall guy but that is. After the festival.
Johnny allen and i went to say the department they said well as i said because we thought. You know.
We've got a half and here thousands of people living up there and.
And how we went to see them and said look we think we've got a better formula than you have.
And it's all about lost and interested because i heard you say the phenomena.
But they were at all impressed with the people. I just thought. We're not going to flood the country with lots of the.
The kid's name and i mean one of the best experiences i had there was this. This family have said you know.
My kids came back with that festival and. I thought that was. That was good for that family.
It was really quite a success that in fact the kids had returned because they came back with attitudes that their
parents probably didn't like. But nevertheless i will back that we're going to do.
Tell it all man to get rid of the press to stores in the fertilizer and the whitechapel and. But that was the.
That was the challenge. Back on their own terms not on their own not my parents.
But didn't give us a lot of money to do it again. But it happened anyway. My people started settling in the valley and.
When i was party to setting up a huge problem. We had two hundred shareholders and.
We bought my wonderful place of land on the waterfront and i was still a member of that person that set that was
and sure. Was when i think he actually. When he was committed to the audiology i lost.
But underneath it all he was actually selling insurance policy and people bought it and i said you know.
Here's the life but. If things get crook. North.
Was a lot of i mean i was the lot of the people started
and i was often back to nimbin a couple of times since the festival. Three times four times something.
And proud that i was part of the idea to bring some life into me but i mean. Very proud. I mean i think it.
I think it worked. It went through a lot of. Heaving problems that went through a lot of conflict.
And it was very painful for a lot of people. To confront that sort of lifestyle and to have their lives disrupted.
In that lie but. In the end. I think that the people who settled there.
And the people who lived there with people who went there twenty years ago. Have now become the establishment. When.
The last time was up to the people who are seeking to get out of it we're now the minority and.
I would call the droogs and. Stablished hippies were becoming sort of like the establishment would wish.
That's what resort. But a lot of them have still got their ideals and.
I got involved in what's called a development control plan with some of the rest
and some we did run some workshops about what direction the town wanted to go in and council. Amazingly.
Were prepared to pass. A lot of the responsibility for pairing. Master plans i've a to a community committee.
Of very responsible. Active people and. They did it and. I mean i was just a facilitator from outside it came in and.
And sort of. You know helped it from a technical point of view.
But i was pleased about that and he was citizens getting up and taking control of the town. Instead of continually.
Belong on the council of things. I mean it's that thing of. Acting locally and.
And not not passing responsible down the law and then getting upset about it in my diet i operations.
Very committed to housing and i'm more involved in in community by staffing. And with an aboriginal work.
I've been working for twenty years with the other show has in company.
And i continually run into people in the bureaucracy
or in powerful positions in government who are used to twenty years ago. Place.
But who i knew had been attracted to the side of sort of things i had been attracted to and.
In some ways that i still had constructed spittal. A lot of them still had a lot of. Audiology and.
The best thing about it was that. You could talk. I could talk to them. From a point of view that you would come from.
And one could appeal to some of their. Earlier instincts and.
And sometimes get to a position where we couldn't have got to had we not known each other we had.
I don't know that i'd be there. To put out a bureaucratic facade.
And a lot of people like that with a lot of goodwill and government. In the public service.
Or actually trying to still do things that are important to people and still reflect empowering local people and.
Gendering somebody of corporation. The article read this as maurice piper was still sighing. Communes and calipso.
One of the sort of acts. That might be side.
But then went cooperatively ran in the in the dairy company from the knees and i would birth in about the naughty
and twenties in effect the cult movement got it's going to start in the carry. Dairy industry in the north coast.
And it's not it's not a big shift. To switch to has in cooperatives it's not a hippie.
Thing at all it's like a lot of sense and. I'm particularly committed to has incorporated as is a bridge between.
Rental and. Have an issue and in working with aboriginal communities and exploring and.
Developing community it can commune some community lot of stalls and. Trouble off stalls.
Hundreds of thousands of years probably.
When that's where the co-operative movement and probably got its origins out of trouble cultures.
And it's interesting that the aboriginal communities around. Lismore.
Actually were a vital part of the aquarius festival as well. When i went there in numbers and i participated and.
That was quite a strong part of the festival and.
The hasn't quite removed it is probably in aboriginal circles is one of the strongest movements in the in the state.
Hundreds of passing cops and. Yourself while quentin and i continue to to develop on come up with principles.
Yeah i don't know the landlord she she was canvassed at the at the festival. Issues of commune ality and.
Life style and. Like some of the aboriginal. People would come to that festival. Talked about the students as.
Whatever originals.
Like that their perception was that a lot of guilty of culture was infecting experimenting with an aboriginal lifestyle.
Like having little impact on the land. Eating more natural materials and.
Acting and into tying themselves in a very aboriginal sort of wide like dancing and singing
and campfire sort of culture was. Was very evident and.
People like harry penrose and lots of people who are aboriginal people. Well connected in the bundjalung. Mob.
Gary williams had gotten involved and. Who had a powerful influence i think and a lot of the thinking. But a burden.
That's how it was used to call her parents but.
I mean he was and has been continuously involved in an alternative lifestyle sort of movement.
And in trying to connect what. Strides with a sort of a tribal culture.